my goal is to get every single single
woman carrying rung condoms just as they
carry around everything else it's like a
no-brainer
I always joke like people just take
selfies with condom
[Music]
I'm Mika Hollander and I'm the
co-founder of sustain which is a brand
of all-natural sexual wellness products
marketed to women if you ask a man what
he thinks of a woman who's carrying
condoms it's negative 90 plus percent of
the time only 19 percent of single
sexually active women use condoms
regularly and one in four college
freshmen actually gets an STD during her
first year at school this is a crisis
and this is a subject that isn't being
talked about because when you think
about condoms and lubricant these are
products that can be seen as taboo women
are extremely uncomfortable buying and
carrying condoms when I go to my peers
and the people that I know they're the
worst offenders we're trying to rebrand
it a little bit and completely empower
women to take control of their sexual
health with much better products most
lubricants out there contain parabens
and clustering and petroleum and
silicone our products have none of those
things
they're aloe and water based it's the
only Fairtrade certified personal gene
free condom on the market in the u.s. we
are starting a conversation that needs
to be had so I spend a lot of time
talking to tumors about why they not
only need to be using our products but
also why they should be just using
condoms in general
you should never feel ashamed for
wanting to or having sex but the reality
is you're out there for you and you need
to protect yourself nobody else is going
to
[Music]